well welcome folks Friday afternoon I
thought we'd have a little bit of fun
how's the conference been
good are you getting tired like three
days is a lot especially did you do
workshops first too
few folks yeah okay it's a lot in a week
and in Italy this is a bit more of
indulgent of a talk uh there folks have
listened to geek outs before know what
I'm talking about
so if you haven't run across these uh on
the dot one of the dot-net Rocks guys
and I'm responsible for the geek out
episodes it was Carl's idea I thought it
was a dumb idea and I was wrong
um and now we've made a better part of a
hundred of them
but they're all the geeky subjects that
I'm interested in which turns out to be
pretty much everything
but I'm good at putting information
together and reading papers and and then
telling a story around it and so
in the old days if you look at this list
we do one a month there's a lot of work
but it was a lot of fun and these days
we probably don't really only do them at
year end
um back in the old days we were doing
three episodes a week and so I didn't
feel so bad about taking one show a
month out of uh out of 12 and saying
let's go talk about
Hypersonic vehicles uh but now that
we're doing one a week I really only do
this at the end of the year and if you
caught the last pair we these were over
Christmas New Year's and I did one on
sort of state of space which I think I
went 90 minutes on and then state of
energy and this talk is very much that
energy talk although I've had a chance
to tailor it more to the UK Market it's
an excuse for me to read all of your
government's paperwork about what they
think they're doing with energy and let
me tell you
those guys write a lot
they are quite wordy so we're talking
about electricity here and it's good to
spend a little bit of time thinking
about how we actually make electricity
the planet is largely dependent on it
now we consume about 15 terawatts at our
Peak consumption times
uh about 160
000 terawatt hours per year
so For Better or Worse our civilization
functions extensively on electricity
these days the key to the whole thing is
the generator
this is the technology uh the one that
won out was Tesla's design for the most
part it's been improved somewhat there
are a few different variations on it but
in the end we have a shaft that's being
spun by some other source
to turn a
an Armature inside of set of of coils
and from that magnetic effect we get a
set of waveforms typical out of a
commercial generator is a three-phase
waveform of electricity and in some I
find it more common in the UK that homes
actually have three-phase power and it's
not all of them it's very unusual in
North America to have three space Power
into the house they're usually only for
commercial sites we have what we call
two leg power which is even stranger
they're 180 degrees out of phase
uh and many places have a single leg
well they only take one and we can talk
about
240 volts versus 120 volts 50 hertz for
60 hertz it's really not that important
uh I know you're really proud of your
plug
the rest of us aren't okay but that's
okay the plug is fine it's also you know
the the the the English plug is like
Lego it's the only thing you really fear
stepping on yeah it's bad news uh
primary way that we spin those
generators is the steam turbine
so there are a variety of ways to make
Steam it has to be high pressure steam
very high temperature we typically think
of steam from the kettle about 100
degrees Celsius
the typical steam that comes into a
turbine like this is about 300 degrees
so we have to do some tricks to get it
that hot and it this is a three stage
almost four stage style turbine if I can
play with my fancy Logitech here
so here's actually the high pressure
stage so that's the hottestine comes in
there first and there's that spins that
part of the shaft and then the pressure
is reduced because it's gone through the
Panorama blade so it goes to What's
called the second stage area and then
this is the third stage of the lowest
pressure
this is a very refined piece of
technology we have built these for a
long time we've built a lot of them and
it's why we tend to make Power using
water steam because we're good at
extracting as much energy from it as
possible and when we get into the
conversation about making energy in
general in some ways this does hold us
back a lot of the Technologies I'm going
to talk about they come down to this
because it's known reliable the main
thing everybody looks for in electricity
is that it works
right we're very unhappy when it doesn't
and so there's a strong disincentive to
innovate
and so now as we're getting into the
world as it stands today we have a
little more energy around
uh that we need to innovate
now I'm going to talk about a lot of
different energies types and so it's
good to have some common measure between
them and the usual one in the industry
is called the levelized cost of energy
and the levelized cost of energy
basically says how much does it cost to
build the plant how much does it cost to
operate and maintain the plant and
ultimately dismantle it over the amount
of time versus the amount of electricity
that it will generate and that will give
us a number and it's typically dollars
per megawatt
and I'm going to focus on the UK since
we happen to be here in in the
government provided me with this lovely
diagram which I really enjoy because I'm
that kind of person
uh because this is the the what we call
the grid right it's at a very high level
we're not getting down to the
nitty-gritty of the grade but we're
looking at the highest voltage lines
that connect throughout the country
notice tightly tied to Ireland but also
plenty of undersea wiring connections to
Norway to Belgium to the Netherlands to
France
uh no grid stands alone except taxes
that's why theirs doesn't work that well
right uh you make more than enough
energy in the UK to supply all of your
homes but you also export a fair bit of
it and import a fair bit of it which I
know seems odd but the reality is that
energy is an Arbitrage business and
sometimes it costs more to make
electricity
and cheaper to buy and sometimes it's
smarter to sell and then buy some back
and so as much as you know you may no
longer be a part of the EU you chills
Transit a lot of electricity backwards
and forwards with a bunch of different
nations that's what a civilization looks
like if you're going to have it work
well and you still do it and those weird
lines that just sort of stop in the
middle of the channel
wind
power plants so you have to run a wire
out to them to bring the electricity
back on land
all right let's go through some of the
sources and how the UK uses it and we're
going to start with coal for a very good
reason you guys started this
now to be clear coal was discovered a
long time ago there is evidence of coal
being burned back in pre-history it was
the rock that burns
but it was that guy
James Watt
and burning coal to make Steam initially
to pump uh uh out mines to manage water
back in the 1700s it really kicked off
the industrial Evolution as we know it
we're we're at the center of all that
the first
coal-based electrical generation power
plant was the Holborn Viaduct station
which is about a half hour walk from
here
it was built by the American Thomas
Edison and it was a DC power plant for
lighting street lights because at that
time you lit your street lights with
flue gas
and caused fires accordingly uh it ran
for about six years until apparently too
much bureaucratic red tape in the middle
1800s made him decide to shut it down
now that bureaucratic tape was actually
the UK government at the time trying to
establish standards around electricity
because different electrical supplies
ran at different voltages and different
cycle rates for different services
so you to this day you still have power
plants that are named for the fact that
they ran street cars and ultimately the
tube and they typically ran at 23 Hertz
at 440 volts
um not the kind of stuff you want to
boil a kettle with
and so the Government tried to
standardize it so you didn't have
different sets of wires for every kind
of power stacked on one on top of each
other that we could build common
infrastructure across all these things
and so at the peak uh at the peak of
utilization in the 90s or in the 70s 90
of the power in the UK was made with
coal you mind a lot of your own coal you
still do most coal these days in the
UK's mind for steel production
anthocytic coal is a necessary part of
making steel less of it is burned you're
down to less than two percent of your
power generation done with coal it's a
handful of coal power plants left and
they are being shut down in the next
couple of years the last of them should
close in 2024.
and part of the reason for that is that
Coal Power production is actually
relatively expensive compared to other
choices today typical lcoe is between 65
and 100 dollars per megawatt
um which is now considered pricey
the reality of course of operating coal
is that you need a tremendous amount of
the stuff so you typically lay a lot of
train lines in directly from the mine
the closer to the mind the better and
you're perpetually 24 hours a day
hauling in tons of coal powdering it
burning it at high temperatures doing
your best to capture the output to boil
water to spin deep words to steam
turbines
and as much as we've tried to mitigate
as much as much of the emissions from
coal we can't get rid of them all so
it's still a fairly toxic way to produce
electricity the uh effluent of coal
burning is not good for you and not good
for the planet
once upon a time we also burned oil then
we decided that was dumb better to put
into cars and distribute the burning all
over the country the few oil power
plants that even existed in the UK
converted to Natural Gas long ago
although most of them have actually been
decommissioned and replaced with far
more efficient gas power plants today
the combined cycle natural gas turbine
power plant is the most efficient power
plant
that does base load burning of a
hydrocarbon
so natural gas is relatively cheap it is
quite plentiful the product despite what
the Russians may have told you
it's common enough in extraction of
various different sources that often is
simply burned off at them at the mining
point
but you can capture It capture it in the
pipes you can liquefy it if you must but
generally using it in gas is the best
way to go the reason the combined cycle
plant is so efficient The Big Box on the
on one side here this thing that's
actually the air box
to make sure the air that it's bringing
in to do all the burning to provide
oxygen for combustion is clean and
efficient here we have the turbine part
so this is very much like a jet turbine
it's running on natural gas and it spins
the generator but it also produces a
tremendous amount of heat and so right
beside this is a steam turbine they use
the excess heat to also generate Steam
and spin a spin turbine which is why
this gets to be so efficient it utilizes
that energy multiple times to extract as
much electricity from it as possible so
nonetheless you get create a fairly good
amount of electricity for its size it
also produces the least amount of carbon
Munitions of a hydrocarbon based power
plant for the megawatts that it produces
and it's cheap relatively speaking these
run about 45 to 75 dollars per megawatt
lcoe
and they're fast so often these plants
are put in place as peaker plants part
of the challenge of running a grid is
you can only you have to make as much
electricity as needs to be consumed at
the time storing it is extremely
difficult and is a relatively new
invention so normally all those folks
that operate those power plants are
literally spinning them up and turning
them down based on your utilization
and of course the UK is famous for the
there are certain television shows that
when they end everybody puts the kettle
on and there's literally people waiting
to turn on power plants to deal with the
end of Coronation Street
um this is more than a third of power
generation in the UK today is now
natural gas some converted plants and
some newly built plants natural gas is
inexpensive it does still have
significant carbon emissions so there
are goals to move away from this but if
you're going to produce carbon dioxide
from Power this is the least offensive
way and uh hopefully he'll get away from
it entirely
the United Kingdom has some of the very
first nuclear power plants in the world
you also had one of the very first
nuclear accidents in the world
congratulations so going back to the
1950s
I did a whole geek out just on nuclear
accidents and I never mentioned the
winscale fire from 57 and I got a lot of
nastygrams about that
because most people think about
Chernobyl Fukushima and Three Mile
Island and arguably uh
wind scale was worse than all of them
except Chernobyl only Chernobyl blew a
core across the countryside
but wind scale burned for three days and
that's really really bad it was also way
at the beginning of nuclear power and
largely people didn't understand how
serious the situation was and and then
those that did really didn't want to
talk about it so the situation far worse
by the way that it was treated
that being said nuclear power has
matured dramatically the power mix at
its peak the UK used made about 26
percent of its power with a nuclear
today it is 16 and it will go down
before it will go up there are only five
major power plants still running
four of them are slated four shut down
in the next couple of years some have
gotten extensions like sizewell
you use a relatively exotic form of
power
the most common nuclear reactors in the
world are the pressurized water reactors
so they take rods of uranium dioxide in
casings in large assemblies they stacked
them together in a big container of
water they then pressurized that water
so that it can get up to the kind of
temperatures needed to spin turbines
that water is in heat exchange with
another loop of water and then that
usually spins the turbine that's the
most common kind you have a couple of
them pressurized water reactors but the
common reactor is this um
Advanced gas reactor that most many
English reactors are like that are this
particular design which uses carbon
dioxide it's an interesting system it
works very well they're also getting old
and so you're turning many of them off
there are two new reactors being built
in the UK right now one is the Hinckley
Point C which actually started
Construction in 2018 it's recently
reported to be 50 percent over budget
and several years behind time now expect
to go into into production by 2027 and
then size well C was only officially
approved for development last year late
last year and so supposed to be ready to
go by 2026.
nuclear power in this traditional format
is expensive the lcoe on it runs 130 to
200 dollars per megawatt so it's not
cost effective compared to many of the
other strategies to make electricity and
that's largely because every nuclear
power plant site is a place for handling
nuclear materials
and that is problematic it means that
its site has to be certified a great
deal it has to have a large exclusion
Zone several kilometers around it can
have can generally not have anybody
living in it
because they refuel the reactors on the
site so they take those fuel assemblies
out of the reactor and they put new ones
in or they'll actually modify them
shuffle them around to consume the fuel
more efficiently and all that fuel
handling takes certification and
extremely qualified people and it takes
a very specialized site that needs to be
routinely expected
and I bring that up because as we talk
about more modern approaches to nuclear
power we've addressed a lot of that and
also being he said modern reactor
designs are far safer than the older
reactor designs we don't have the
problems that cause situations like
Chernobyl and Fukushima so forth
Fukushima is only 2011 but the reactor
design was much older
there were three or four reactors that
got damaged in in Fukushima there were
actually two others that nobody ever
talks about reactor five and six they
were running at the time of the
earthquake
but they were a slightly more modern
version of that same reactor that is
passive shutdown so even though they
also got hit by the tsunami and their
generators were also destroyed didn't
matter they cooled themselves down the
older designs could needed powered cool
down they failed
today react no reactor is built
requiring active cooling they all have
passive shutdown Solutions and so are
all the new reactors that you're
building
uh I should talk briefly about biomass
it is a carbon emitting power approach
nobody builds power Mass because they
want to make electricity what they have
is excess materials available that can
be made into Power these are power
plants of opportunity essentially you'll
find them around
places that are manufacturing things
that have aggro waste products like if
you're refining sugar you have an
effluent that can be burned for
electricity they tend to be small make a
lot or two at most
the price lcoe can be pretty good down
to 50 up as high as 150 but again you
wouldn't do these at scale so you have
several hundred of them scattered across
the countryside wherever there are
materials that need to would otherwise
be a waste product can be made into
electricity
and so it's a I mentioned it just
because well it doesn't amount to much
in the overall power generation it makes
less power than your coal power plants
do it is a source of power based on us
trying to be efficient
thermal power is not something that you
do in the UK there's been a couple of
experiments over the year but the most
part doesn't happen this man it's funny
because it's not that far away you've
got Iceland in that's all they seem to
be doing these days
um
the reality of course is as you dig down
into the ground you hit hot rocks and if
you dig far enough you hit really hot
rocks and if you send water down there
it will come back hot and then you can
spin turbines the problem is that the
drilling part is the expensive part and
your ground is notoriously hard
and very very difficult to get difficult
to drill into and so it's just not a lot
of incentive to develop out here there
are places where it's really the only
choice Iceland being one of them where
it's hard to make Power almost any other
way and their depth of drill is very
short if you can drill less than two
kilometers geothermal becomes a much
more effective strategy that being said
and I mentioned this in the last energy
geek out there is a new technology
available for geothermal using high
energy microwaves to do the drilling
and this is an important innovation
because normally when you're drilling
with a grinding tool the grinding tool
is being destroyed in the process and
the harder the rock is the more often
you're going to need to replace those
tools and as you get down deep you have
a lot of pressure involved and so you're
pumping drilling mud to try and maintain
your your drill as well as remove the
materials pump back up again and so
shutting down to replace a drill bit is
a very complicating costly process
you're also inserting casings to keep
the drill hole from collapsing all of
that is complex and in a something
straight out of Star Trek they've made
this large extremely high powered
microwave that vaporizes Rock and in the
process deposits on the side of the hole
that it's making to be a natural casing
as you go
I mean it sounds like a science fiction
novel until you see the video of them
doing it you're like okay that thing's
badass
it's very short range so it's not good
for a weapon like it can't go up and
hold it against the guy and say hold
this for a second while I turn this
thing on but in the prospects of my of
drilling a pipe four to five four or
five kilometers underground it's very
interesting and so that's a new
technology just beginning to come down
the pipeline that may open geothermal
for a lot of us because geothermal
essentially has no emissions
if you do it properly which is that you
have a closed loop heat Loop where you
you're pumping water down in sealed
pipes and it's coming back up another
pipe as Steam and then you heat exchange
against it to actually spin your turbine
and send the same water back down again
you'd almost have no emissions of any
kind and you don't really need other
sources of water like it becomes a
really interesting solution so we may
see more of this in the future
to use electric power if you have an
urge to spend a lot of money on
electricity this is the way to go
uh so you're literally talking about
burning making a giant diesel engine
as in the fuel tank will be underground
the oil tank will be underground you'll
have a series of Motors that are
connected to those loops and you run
them 24 hours a day to spin generators
to generate electricity
but again depending on your location
this may be the only choice so you look
at places like the Galapagos Islands is
technically not inhabitable by humans
but if you put in a power plant like
this typically no bigger than five to
ten megawatts it's enough to sustain a
small population of people with
electricity you know in the case of
Galapagos they use a bunch of it to
desalinate drinking water from the ocean
too yeah the UK doesn't use these
there's no reason to it is very much the
power of Last Resort
hydroelectric not a huge amount of power
in the UK made with hydroelectric I'm
from British Columbia where we got
mountains so that's what we do and the
Norwegians very much the same situation
uh
they tend to be very large projects so
they're costly to develop but they last
an extremely long time typically many
power plants are good to 20 to 40 years
um
sometimes 50 or 60. Hydro runs 100 plus
with maintenance you can keep them going
for a very long time so the price comes
in at lco of around 40 to 50 dollars
that's pretty effective you do have some
hydroelectric it's still only about two
percent of your power but the um
Kyle their water power plant 60
gigawatts six gigawatts that's a good
size
uh Dam and as long as you have water
they keep working
sometimes you don't have water just ask
the Hoover Dam
all right let's talk about the new stuff
let's talk about onshore wind
so the UK has an interesting mix of both
onshore and offshore sort of equal wind
power is the growth area it's also
currently the cheapest source of
electricity available on the planet
today so an lcoe of around 25 to 50
dollars so 25 dollars a megawatt it's
very very inexpensive and that it
certainly creates part of the appeal of
that and there's a reason for that the
amount of money that's been spent
developing wind energy is extensive and
so today we have multi megawatt offshore
wind turbines they are massive and
Incredibly reliable that being said 10
20 years is typically a lifespan for a
wind turbine and you'll change out
blades and replace components over time
so you have about 11 000 turbines in the
UK these days split evenly between
onshore and off the onshores are smaller
cheaper to install
they're not as popular with the populace
people don't like looking at them they
do Make Some Noise there is the issue of
bird strikes although I would argue that
currents the the current metrics show
that as many as a half a million birds
are killed per year by wind turbines
compared to two and a half million birds
can be killed by domesticated cats
so if you're really worried about the
birds keep your cat inside I mean not
that every cat kills Birds but there was
this great study of the University of
Virginia where they put cameras on
domestic house cats that are normally
outside and it's like only 20 of them
killed but they were psychotic murderers
they killed constantly and clearly for
fun
so yeah if you got one of those cats you
can make a big big help by keeping that
one inside
so onshore well known kind of at its
limits for what it can do and there's
only so much land to go around offshore
clearly more interesting although
there's really two classes of offshore
the typical offshore and certainly what
exists in the UK is more of a near shore
system typically no more than 50 meters
of water which is most of the channel
so if you remember that map that I
showed briefly all of those wires are
sort of ending in the water we're all in
in the channel because the water's
shallow and so literally you're driving
a placement down into the bottom from
the surface of the water draining it
pouring a bunch of concrete into that
shaft and sticking the wind turbine on
top and then the rest of it can be
maintained over time
uh and these still have shorebird issues
and they are only in certain locations
so it limited limits where you can put
them they can only get so big they are
hazards to shipping so they try and keep
them in uh set in certain areas
there is development going off in true
offshore winds so this is wind with
stabilized platforms they're floating
platforms that are that have cable
anchored or there's a few different ways
to stay them
this is directly derived from the oil
rig industry so they're going to be more
expensive to make but they can be
dramatically larger
and wind flows further offshore are more
stable and the bigger platforms allow
them to get to better wind all in all so
this probably is the future of wind
power you will still have the problem of
they need to be maintained so folks need
to go out there to do work on them and
you do need to get the power back sure
so you're running very long cables
but in exchange for they are out of
sight so out of mind
they're in the bigger ocean where
there's room to move around and
generally fewer problems with hazards of
navigation and we're certainly getting
the build quality this will probably
continue to be the least expensive power
going for quite some time and it has a
lot of advantages
solar I'm going to start with solar
thermal because everybody talks about
voltaics but solar thermal is also a
form of heat this is what they call a
heliostat type solar this is actually
one of one of the plants that's in
Morocco so what you're doing here is you
have electrically guided mirrors every
one of those dots is a mirror with a two
axis motor on it that can constantly
adjust itself to reflect the sun into
that Central Point at the top of the
mast
and at the top of the mass is a big big
block of graphite that's pumping a
lithium beryllium salt through it now
lithium William fluorine salts are only
a liquid at 400 degrees Centigrade but
they stay a liquid until 1500 degrees
Centigrade you know as opposed to water
which only zero to a hundred so there's
some advantages to using those kinds of
salts heated by the sun there they can
hold so much heat they'll run overnight
so even when the sun's down you have
enough heat left in the salt Loop that
you can continue to run turbines 24
hours a day if you can get sufficient
size
unlike photovoltaic solar panels they
don't care how hot it gets solar panels
really don't like heat heliostats
couldn't care less so this is why places
like Morocco built these gigantic
gigawatt power plants running on salt so
they are 24-hour day power just powered
by the Sun as long as your Sun every day
which typically there is but it won't
last more than a couple of days
unfortunately operationally they are
still expensive 120 150 dollars per
megawatt and the reason is a lot of
Maintenance all of the motors for all of
those heliostats need to be routinely
maintained the heliostats have to be
kept clean the assault Loop is the least
maintenance part of the system it's
quite immature but to collect that much
sunlight takes a bunch of moving parts
and moving parts and deserts have their
challenges
photovoltaic is the second least exp the
second cheapest power source out there
at the commercial scale
so when you're building commercial large
arrays of panels collecting sunlight it
becomes quite expensive we largely have
the Chinese to thank for this they were
the ones who built power that built
solar panel Factories at such a scale
they drove the price down to that again
in the 28 to 35 dollar per megawatt
class very very inexpensive power
now the technology is interesting it is
layers of silicon and a few other
substrates is manufactured in much the
same way that our microprocessors are
made
part of the reason we were able to make
them relatively cheaply they only
collect about 20 maybe 22 percent of the
sunlight they hit
if you're standing on the equator at
noon when the sun is directly overhead
you get about a kilowatt of sunlight
hitting a square meter
it's about 1400 before you go through
the atmosphere you lose a bunch of it to
get through the atmosphere that's when
the atmosphere is effectively the
thinnest it's perfectly clear this is
the optimal situation
and then with a typical the this style
of photovoltaic you're only going to
collect about 220 watts of that
now let's get off the equator and up
here in the land of the gray and so we
get a lot we have more atmosphere to go
through we don't have as much Clear
sunlight days but the still because
these panels are so cheap it's worth it
the Germans spent a lot on this and they
quickly they have now learned to stop
pointing their panels South they Point
their panels East and West because the
individual panels are cheap enough now
that it's not we don't need power in the
middle of the day we need power earlier
and later and so we get less yield per
panel for spreading out our power
generation over the course of the day
but that's how far
photovateic has come
so uh
another downside
space consumption is substantial
so it takes about 20 times more land to
generate a gigawatt of Power with solar
panels than it does with a traditional
power plant like a combined cycle gas
turbine on the other hand
lifespans are good more than 20 years no
moving Parts no fuel relatively little
maintenance they do need to be washed
occasionally let them get too dirty and
wiring does corrode like there's some
maintenance to them but the maintenance
costs are quite low
the long the hotter they get the less
time they last
they prefer about 25 degrees Centigrade
and so you generally think in the UK
that's not a big deal but I saw what you
did last summer
and that can cost you a half a percent
per year in terms of efficiency so they
do Decay over time you don't tend to
have very large solar plants in the UK
the biggest is about 75 megawatts which
is Big that's a lot of room but it's
there are gigantic ones in other places
like Australia where they have lots and
lots of land
um but there's over a thousand
commercial
uh Power array solar power arrays in the
UK now so it's popular and they're
getting up to
um several percentage points of your
overall power generation win by far the
most popular but yeah solar's doing well
we're starting to get clever with our
solar too we're doing things like
putting them on the reservoirs of dams
for a few reasons I mean one is that's
open space you know it's typically not
particularly biologically sensitive you
made the reservoir in the first place so
you can mess with it the water helps
keep the the panels cool so they stay
they last longer and covering the water
keeps the reservoir Fuller
you have a reduced evaporation in India
they're putting solar panels over top of
their irrigation canals it retains water
it generates electricity and it
decreases the amount of algal growth in
the canal so it's all mutually
beneficial in exchange for making a more
complicated installation off off and not
in the perfect orientations but has some
advantages
residential solar
um doing fairly there's over a million
homes apparently in the UK now that have
solar panels on them which sounds like a
lot Until you realize that's like less
than three percent so it's not wildly
popular compared to a place like
Southeastern Australia where they're
close to 20 percent
but they have a lot more sunlight It's
relatively expensive 150 200 per
megawatt lcoe but that's not how you
typically measure it and it's like later
we get later into this talk I'll talk
more about what the powers of having
solar local to your house you are
they're often buy back Solutions which
seems to be common in the UK where if
you're making more power than you need
the power company will pay you something
typically as a credit because you're
going to need it back from them
eventually anyway sometimes it's dark
um but they say almost six gigawatts of
power could be produced on an Ideal day
with the residential solar that exists
inside of the UK right now it will never
be that much because that's not how
things work out but it does speak to
there's a lot of solar panels out there
there are more efficient solar panels
these arguably the main feature of these
silicon solar panels is that they're in
it relatively inexpensive and they're
reliable they're a very known entity we
know how long they last we know how they
break down we know how to maintain them
we know how to control them well there's
a popular technology being developed
right now called proskite solar it's
substantially more efficient it's also
very thin they can even be made
transparent it gets up to about 30
percent it also is a little less
resource intensive you don't need as
much silica you don't need as much
titanium however
a little pricey and they have durability
problems they're very intolerant to
excess heat and so there's a lot of
maturation that has to go into the
development of these panels before they
might be good enough for commercial
grade so if you're wondering like why
are we still using the crappy solar
panels they told us there would be
better ones they're trying
but there's a lot of things that go into
a workable power source
both with wind and solar we have the
problem of sometimes it's not windy
sometimes it's not sunny and we need
power storage power storage has come a
long way in the past few years for
better or worse our buddy you on by the
way I miss old Elon I miss I miss the
let's fly my sports car into space Elon
that guy was cool this guy's crazy
but he also helped mature the
lithium-ion battery to the point where
they're now doing grid scale power using
lithium ion now lithium-ion is not well
suited for this task Lithium-ion
batteries focused mostly on rapid
charging relatively rapid discharging
and lightweight all things that are good
for a car but not especially important
for grid power
we're making better Lithium-ion
batteries we're starting to learn to
optimize them for other roles so the
lithium phosphate batteries are a little
better for this but they're not optimal
there are better Technologies out there
now there are big battery packs in
Australia they've got gigawatt packs
down there there's uh the hillswood
project here in the UK is about a 200
megawatt hour
battery system based on the Tesla Mega
packs this exact thing that I'm showing
you here so there is a beginning of
starting to create power sources that
will bridge in between
Renewables and also for switching
sometimes you want to switch from one
source to the other lithium-ion battery
packs can switch onto the grid very very
quickly and so there are good they're an
alternative for temporary transfers and
possibly even to the far as a peaker
plant
there are new battery technologies being
developed one of the folks that came
from Tesla but now is working on his own
form energy
has now got enough funding that they're
building their first plants based on
what's called an iron air battery this
is technology developed by NASA back in
the 50s and 60s and they've now pursued
it further to mature it looking at it as
a better technology for the grid iron
air means much less expensive lithium is
relatively costly to extract iron is
extremely common you are yes storing
energy in Rust which is disturbing but
it's cost effective it also runs pretty
hot it's relatively large
but none of those things are important
for grid scale right in the end I find
that it's big hot and heavy is fine
you're going to put it in an acreage
behind a fence
the most important thing when you look
at iron air batteries is they have
naturally long run times so normal
discharge rate for lithium-ion battery
is typically six to eight hours is about
as long as you would normally get power
from it you can charge it up very very
quickly but you know it won't really
hold power forever
line iron air batteries have about a
hundred hour natural discharge cycle and
so they take longer to charge but they
hold that charge very well and they can
discharge over long periods of time so
they're better suited for overnight
bridging of a wind uh farm so you
imagine building out a wind farm that
while the wind's blowing it charges
batteries and provides electricity when
the wind's not blowing you're getting
that same amount of electricity from the
battery system the first of these are
being deployed this year Minnesota and
Georgia are getting the first form
energy plant so they're the beginning of
this that wasn't that long ago that uh
that Tesla was deploying their first
batteries only three or four years ago
so we're making progress in this area
far more common when it comes to storing
power is pumped storage
so this is the idea that while I have
extra electricity hanging around I use
it to pump water uphill into a reservoir
and then when I need it I let it come
back downhill and I spin turbines with
it there have been some dedicated
storage sites this is literally a
diagram from a site in the U.S called
the Raccoon Mountain Storage site so it
was never a dam it was literally built
for the purpose of being pumped storage
and so it helps us offset when we have
more power than we need we can pump
water uphill but it's also becoming more
common today
to add to existing hydroelectric dams
some pump storage capabilities because
we're finding more and more that our
reservoirs aren't full all the time the
change in rain patterns and things that
meant where that our reservoirs are
lower and so we are being able to pump
water back uphill we have Excess power
back to that idea of putting solar
panels on my reservoir
one of the things I can do with those
solar panels is pump water back up into
the reservoir
so the reservoir gives me my on-demand
power and then when I have Excess power
I'm using solar panels to to recover it
I know it sounds weird it's like hey you
just let that water go down to make the
electricity like why would you pump it
back up typically I have reservoirs
sitting below the dam as well or I have
other sources of water that are coming
through the area and so I can pick up
that water and pump it uphill when I
have water available for that so pump
storage is the most common power storage
system we actually have they've been
around a long time but we're taking them
more and more seriously
the current estimate between pump
storage and some of the Battery Systems
coming along online right now is that
the UK actually is capable of storing up
at about one percent of the power that
it consumes in a given day
that's still a lot of megawatts but it
also speaks to a lot further to go
so I've run down the different Power
Solutions and this is sort of the where
we are in society uh where some power
sources have gotten less expensive some
have got more expensive interesting that
the uh the zero emission ones are
becoming the cheapest wind and solar
natural gas is the next cheapest it's
still a uh a petrochemical based power
source but it's relatively inexpensive
nuclear tends to be absurdly expensive
coal has gotten more expensive over time
and gas speaker plants are costly but
they're different from the regular
natural gas ones because they're fast on
Fast off
and looking at the planet as a whole
we're a long way away from getting to
full Renewables if you look at this
graph it's not going to make you happy
down at the bottom there that
traditional biomass that's burning wood
would not recommend
but coal oil natural gas the vast
majority of all the terawatt hours made
on this planet and then up in this
cluster right at the top is our various
Renewables whether it's solar wind Hydro
nuclear is not technically renewable but
at least it's a zero emission power
let's talk about hydrogen
not because the news is good
so there's three kinds of hydrogen
essentially we so the way we've defined
it there's the gray hydrogen which is
really us make taking natural gas and
steam refactoring it so that we blow off
the carbon dioxide from it and keep the
hydrogen so yeah I'm using hydrogen I
just had to emit a whole lot of carbon
dioxide to have it it's also the
cheapest way to do it there's blue
hydrogen where we're still taking
typically natural gas and blowing the
carbon dioxide off it but we're
capturing the carbon dioxide
and then green hydrogen the one
everybody wants to talk about which is
where we use electricity to split water
to create hydrogen and release oxygen as
a as a waste product
so let's talk about the differences
between them so vast majority of
hydrogen production today irrespective
of using it in these new ways but when
we've always needed hydrogen we've done
steam
refractions so we pump in methane our
natural gas and we burn it we get it up
to very high temperatures there's a
little chemical reactions there and
we're able to peel off the carb the
hydrogen that way and we make a lot of
carbon dioxide and there's a few
different ways to try and capture that
and then you try and utilize that carbon
dioxide sometimes it shows up in
Coca-Cola
it takes about six megawatt hours of
electricity
to produce a ton of of hydrogen hydrogen
is very low density
and you'll make about 10 tons of carbon
dioxide in the process
for six megawatt hours of electricity
if you're willing to spend a bit more
energy there is this thing called
methane paralysis so now you're pumping
the car the the natural gas into the
bottom of a catalytic reaction you're
pumping about seven to eight megawatt
hours of power into it that higher
pressures of temperatures the chemical
reaction actually turns blows the oxygen
off the carbon so you get dry carbon
from it stuff you can hold on to and
then you're emitting oxygen and hydrogen
so better
these are more expensive to build
they're not the cheapest way to do it
they are becoming more popular we're
seeing more plants being built this way
because you can manage the carbon pretty
easily it's a dry hard product it's
sellable too but it's straight carbon if
you want to bury you do
and everybody's favorite the blue uh the
green hydrogen which is where we
make uh hydrogen out of water
so what's the problem
well it was about six megawatt hours to
make a ton of hydrogen in the gray
approach it's 40.
for electrolysis
but yeah you're gonna you're gonna split
it in half you're gonna make eight tons
of oxygen for one ton of hydrogen
hydrogen's very light but Ash is not a
big deal
it's just not cost effective it's
incredibly expensive to make hydrogen
this way
you need a lot of electricity to do it
and so it's why there's so little of it
in the world they figure less than four
percent of hydrogen production on the
planet is done through electrolysis
because it just is a massive power sink
they're getting better at Building
Systems like this they can use Excess
power often we're making solar and wind
when we don't need them
and it's a problem to manage that and so
one of the options is you switch over to
an electrolysis method and so you burn
up that excess electricity by making
hydrogen
so we're starting to see combined cycle
systems out on the floating arrays of of
Soul of uh wind turbines where they
actually have the electrolysis unit on
site and they're storing hydrogen on
site as well as making electricity when
there's excess electricity being
produced they can actually tell them to
switch over and make hydrogen from it as
well it's clever long way to go
let's go back to nuclear because I only
talked about traditional nuclear and
obviously the UK is doing some of that
the hip new approach that's been talked
about for years and years is small
modular reactors
and this has been a pipe dream for a
really long time but 2022 was a good
year
because 202 was the year that several
different small modular projects got
approved and some even started
Construction
so the core concept the most important
thing you take away from understanding
small modular is that the site that runs
the power plant never handles the
radioactive material
so the radioactive materials that go
into these reactors are handled in a
factory so there's one place that's
certified to process those reactors to
actually assemble them to handle the
nuclear material they put together a
small modular reactor the kind that can
fit on the back of a truck I know it
seems weird to want to move that stuff
around by truck but you if you're
building nuclear power plants you move
reactor fuel around all the time this
we're mailed in small enough that the
whole reactor fits in and so a given
site would have a bunch of reactors they
typically run for two years before they
need refueling
so you stagger their implementation you
can take them out and reprocess them
they tend to be small enough that they
can't actually melt down they don't have
enough fuel in them so you never wreck
the site you can wreck the reactor then
you take the reactor out and haul it
away
so there's a few things that come from
doing it this way you have one place to
get certified for handling nuclear fuel
the the factory
sites don't need as much containment
they don't need the biggest perimeters
they don't have any fuel handling they
just take old reactors or even replace
them you also means that every couple of
years you get to upgrade reactors so
rather than us building out these
bespoke massive concrete things distinct
to one implementation of of power and
then after 30 40 or 60 years we get to
do something with it or we shut it down
in need usage to do modifications to it
every two years you get to put a new
reactor in
now most small modular are Rel this is
the design from new scale this is now a
improved design by the Americans the
national uh
nuclear service approve this reactor it
can now be deployed that being said
nobody's buying at this particular point
there are several interested parties
but these were only 60 megawatts
reactors they're relatively compact
which is why they fit so neatly the way
they do
in Canada Ontario specifically 80 of its
power comes from nuclear mostly the
can-do reactor which is a particular
design but those mod those designs are
aging out they just approved a location
to put a small modular reactor design
from GE atachi it's not that small
actually it's a 300 megawatt reactor so
it's a pretty good size but it is
developed and constructed off-site and
then put into place
that same thing it's going to have run
time for a couple of years and then they
replace it with a new one
and so the idea being that over time we
build a fat we build these fat a factory
or two and we keep improving reactor
designs and rotating through different
sites
and where you're seeing 10 to 20 year
construction times for reactor sites
because of all the bespoke behavior and
certification and so forth they're
talking about being able to build them
in 48 months
but they haven't done it yet
so I expect the Darlington site which is
in Ontario which is underway to go over
time because it's the first
but at least the methodology they're
using gives us a hope that we could do
this quickly what we like about these
power these power technician
Technologies no emissions
simple you know reliable operations
we've now matured most of the big
problems out of it it doesn't need a lot
of external support it doesn't need a
constant supply of fuel coming in you're
talking about refueling every couple of
years
so and in in Canada where we have very
northern areas where there's you know
where solar and wind are simply not
feasible these small reactor designs
might be exactly we need to support
those Folks up north because right now
they're burning diesel
that's not good for any of us
the folks at Rolls-Royce have a design
they're very keen to get certified for
about a 450 megawatt uh modular reactor
that they want the UK to support
specific to here so you may have seen it
on the news they were talking about it
fairly recently it looks very similar it
spokes it speaks to these same key
issues central location for manufacturer
can be deployed in multiple sites one
location to certify and then the actual
reactor sites don't handle materials
so let's be funner we're geeks let's
talk about Fusion
I don't know if you've noticed but
they've been building a plant in in
France for a really long time
uh
there's the joint European tourist jet
which is actually here in the UK built
in the 1990s and it does it does
deterior tritium Fusion it does it with
with copper coils to compress a plasma
to the point of fusing which really did
work and its best run ever was in 1998
when they put 16 megawatts of energy
into the plasma and got about 14 back
they didn't capture it that's what they
measured
so it was a queue of 0.7 or 0.69 at the
time it was a big deal at the time the
reactor design is relatively old it's
from the 90s Eider the big upgrade for
Eider it's a much larger reactor but
they're also using superconductive
magnetic coils they use niobium tin
cooled in liquid helium to compress the
field or at least they will
someday they've been building it for a
really long time because it's an
international Consortium that Taurus the
donut that's being built there is being
built in eight segments in eight
countries
because that's an efficient way to do
things but remember this is one of the
ways you get this is the same reason
they did this with the International
Space Station when you get multiple
countries involved in this treaties and
so forth you're more likely to actually
finish it the Americans started out
going on their own they were going to
build their own giant Taurus and they
could cancel that the next
Administration and it went away so now
they're participating in either
supposed to get
to a queue of one so same amount of
power in same amount of power out it's
still a test design
there are more advanced designs out
there so the folks at MIT have a company
called Commonwealth Fusion where they're
using rebco field coils so niobium 10 is
sort of a traditional superconductor
cool with liquid helium rebco it means
Rare Earth barium cupric oxides
you you've seen all these little videos
of them with a petri dish with a little
Cube floating they pour liquid nitrogen
over to make it float that's a Revco
they're Ceramics so they don't make good
wire
it's taken decades for them to figure
out how to actually turn it into a film
that you can wrap into a coil
and Commonwealth Fusion folks have built
the first part of their reactor and show
they can really make a superconductive
coil cooled liquid nitrogen much less
expensive and difficult but makes a much
more powerful magnetic field than
niobium 10. it's a breakthrough and so
their reactor is smaller cheaper and
lighter and good enough that Bill Gates
kicked in a whole bunch of money
so we may actually see a reactor one of
these days the problem of course is that
deuterium tritium Fusion I'm going to
say of course like all of Europe on this
so why do we use what is deuterium
tritium these are isotopes of hydrogen
regular hydrogen has a proton in the new
an electron that's it if you get a
neutron involved that's deuterium
deuterium is naturally occurring it's
about one percent of seawater the water
is actually heavy water being that it
has deuterium as the hydrogen atoms in
the water don't drink it
apparently it's sweet it's just not good
for you okay and we can extract that in
the can-do Rea uh fission reactors in
the uh in Canada we use heavy water
because those neutrons are useful for
power exchange
tritium they have two neutrons
now when you're doing Fusion you're
making helium out of hydrogen so you're
banging the heat hydrogen yeah they're
so hard the protons end up sticking
together and they're really like doing
that so they complain loudly to
management in the form of a very big
burst of energy
and but helium needs a pair of neutrons
to be stable
and so by using tritium and deuterium
you have three neutrons available and so
they slam together and two of those
neutrons become the helium and one of
those neutrons spins off
and that becomes our best opportunity to
extract power except that neutrons can't
be contained by magnetic fields because
they're neutrons
and so they actually do a lot of damage
the the jet Taurus when they ran did
those big runs with it back in the day
it basically powdered the inside of the
containment vessel the neutron damage
from it
so if we were actually going to make a
power plant like this we have to
understand that a you need a ton of
tritium tritium is not naturally
occurring you have to make it
so you have to actually run a machine
that breaks lithium apart to spit out
tritium that's going to consume a bunch
of energy
that makes you enough tritium to run
your DT Fusion
but you're going to routinely now you
have to capture neutrons the useful way
I would recommend a big wall of molten
lead which takes a lot of energy to run
but you're going to capture that Neutron
in there and generate more heat and that
should give you enough to spin some
steam turbines
but this is going to be free
it's not you know you keep talking about
making power from seawater saying you
know except for the tritium
we could do few other kinds of fusion
there are kinds of fusion called
anisotropic Fusion so it's fusions that
do not emit neutrons and if you're
interested in this stuff I would go look
at a company called try Alpha energy
they have a pulse and reactor design
that could get to the point it doesn't
yet of doing proton Boron Fusion but it
needs about a hundred million degrees as
opposed to about the 10 million degrees
needed for DT Fusion
the other Improvement besides these new
kinds of coils is we started using
machine learning models to understand
plasmas and so we're now going to use
sophisticated software based on machine
learning to manipulate plasmas to keep
them stable for longer so we can
generate more energy so there's been
some good technology developed over time
studying Fusion if you think Fusion's
just not made any progress I'm here to
show you the little bits that it has
they used to say Fusion is only 30 years
away and it has been 30 years away for
50 years
20 years away
and the problem is it's billions to go
and so considering the crisis we have
and the interest we have in making
cleaner power right now as much as I
love this
it's not the best of use of money at the
time I'd rather be building a lot more
small modular reactors to make zero
emission energy they and spend less on
this if I have to trade the two I prefer
not to trade the two I'd like us to do
both the the fusion power has a whole
lot of benefits for things like buying a
bill of flying spacecraft and thing long
term
but it's a long way from being a power
source still
we are getting smarter about our grids
so we're learning to make power in more
places that's been part of the problem
with getting good at wind power and
solar arrays and so forth as we're used
to having a few large power plants and
made it pretty easy to keep the grid
stable now we're having lots of
different power plants including power
right at the house this is where we get
into the whole conversation about uh
residential solar that our houses can be
part of operating themselves
the power companies don't want you to
sell power back to them it's not easy to
use in fact it's largely impossible to
use but it's one of our incentives to do
that what they really like about you
generating your own power is that you
stop consuming theirs at least at times
and so that all that offset mechanism is
a secondary but you're seeing now is
that we're getting local battery
Solutions as well these are the Tesla
power walls and so they work very neatly
with solar to offset the power the
reality for us is that our power
consumption varies over the course of a
day typically the highest power
consumption in a given day is around the
time everybody gets home from work and
kids are back and it's time to make
dinner
and you probably you're probably going
to run the hob you're right we're on the
dishwasher you may be doing dishes it's
a huge spike in power consumption for an
hour or so and if you got an electric
car you plugged it in when you came back
so you kind of made the worst case
scenario and they pretty much have to
provision for all of that power at once
and that's when they turn on peaker
plants and other nasty polluting things
what if you could be using your
batteries at that moment
the power you collected over the course
of the day with whatever little sunlight
we got that day there was a little today
gives enough power and that we gotta
maybe uh 14 kilowatt hours of
electricity in these two power walls and
that should be enough to get you through
dinner
better still will be to make our
appliances smarter
so that we don't do dishes immediately
we make sure they're clean by morning
we're getting pushed to Muse more and
more electricity actually right they're
saying stop using gas for your heat use
a heat pump more electricity they're
asking us to use induction stoves which
by the way are very cool
but also consume a lot of electricity
so we're going to increase our
dependence on electricity to do histor
emissions
right down to the electric car as well
the electric car is an interesting
option because it's a pretty good
battery we are starting to see systems
now where we can use that battery for
our homes
it's not necessarily good for the
battery that battery is designed to work
the way a car works or bursts of power
then and then charge later where the way
we consume power in a house a little
different from that but in general for
us as software people the opportunity to
make the house smarter all around
so that we can communicate with the
power grid and find and have variable
rate electricity
we're saying some places now where the
the price of electricity varies hour to
hour
so you can imagine with some good
software with your appliances you could
be telling your dishwasher hey make sure
these dishes are are clean by morning
he loaded it at night but he won't wash
it till sometime in the middle of night
now you could figure that out hey maybe
4 AM is the right time
but better with a smart grid that'll
actually say okay well I can run this
off a battery
or maybe the local wind turbine kicks up
because it's windy right now and that's
basically free power so I'll do it now
right that ability to select and also to
converse with the grid into offset so
the grid has an easier time of dealing
with these things I work for some folks
in the Netherlands that are doing this
with their electric cars because the
electric car to band around dinner time
was so bad it was browning out the
affluent neighborhoods because they're
the ones with the Teslas right and all
you got to do is brown out one affluent
neighborhood and boy action gets taken
and so now there's a the power points in
that part of the world when you plug it
in it negotiates with the grid for when
to charge and it'll do an assessment
like how how much charge you've got and
can it get you to the hospital if it
can't okay I'm gonna give you enough
power to get to the nearest hospital and
then I'm going to wait and later in
night I'm going to offset charging for
all the cars in the in the homes in that
area so that we don't stress the grid
and everybody gets a charge by morning
we've got work to do it's software
people with all of these things it's
interesting times they're going to make
better and better power sources but
they're also asking us to use more and
more electricity so we're going to have
to get smarter about it and nobody wants
to pay attention to this stuff
you know 12 cents a kilowatt hour or
even 20 cents kilowatters not enough for
you to pay attention
but our software could
I hope this was useful for you if you
haven't run across the show before
there's a shortcut link called
geekout.show that'll take you to the 100
or so geek outs we've done I'll continue
to do them at least once a year on this
these topics in the space ones maybe a
couple others if you ask thanks so much
for your time
[Applause]